[Música]
puede que no vayan a creer lo siguiente
para hace unos cuantos años para mí era
imposible el considerar pararme hablar
en público para que me entiendan yo no
podía llegar a un salón de clases
regresando de vacaciones y platicar en
frente de la clase qué es lo que había
hecho en mi vacaciones de verano
tanto hacia la cosa que en mi escuela
pasada prefirió sacar a cero mis
presentaciones finales a pasar en frente
a platicar qué es lo que tenía que
platicar hasta que un día mi papá se le
ocurrió la grandiosa idea de mandarme un
campamento de verano en eeuu con tan
siquiera tenía 14 años yo dije bueno de
ir mi hijo a ser sólo el ig nobel
total que él quería que fuera solo
porque quería que yo aprendiera a
comunicarme con otras personas que no
conocía también quería que yo
desarrollar nuevas habilidades y total
yo le dije está bien pero por debajo de
la mesa fui con unos amigos y les empecé
a vender la idea de crear un campamento
de verano es en eeuu hay unas gringas y
total ya que tuve que vender nada y
ellos ya estaban convencidos total
empezaron a ver con sus papás su papá
les dieron permiso del campamento y
total cuando ya ir mi papá ya era muy
tarde como para que mi papá y ser algo
al respecto
tal siente cosas que sé yo estoy en
camino a san francisco con mis otros
amigos y cuando llegamos llegamos un
auditorio donde habían más de 250
estudiantes de todas las partes del
mundo y la gente brasil de canadá de
eeuu de costa rica todo mundo estaba ahí
y cuando llegó empieza la inauguración y
el encargado del campamento se empieza a
introducir y empresa se empieza a
introducir a todos los maestros que nos
iban a estar ayudando y atendiendo a
través de las dos semanas del campamento
total con dios terminan de presentarse
el encargado vuelve a tomar puede a
subirse el escenario y nos dice bueno ya
que nos conocieron a todos nosotros
ahora nosotros queremos conocerlos
algunos de ustedes
y yo me acuerdo que cuando me tuve esa
disputa con mi papá de que si quería ir
que no quiere ir yo dije no pago no sé
es que todo prometer una cosa voy a
tratar de aprovechar cualquier
oportunidad que se me presente durante
el campamento ya sea participar en las
actividades o cualquier cosa que me haga
sobresalir porque sería muy enojado que
he dicho a mis dos amigos por debajo de
la mesa total cuando ya llegamos al
campamento y el encargado dice caro nos
quiere conocer a nosotros nos pregunta
quién está que quiere pasar al frente y
decir cómo se llaman de dónde son y algo
interesante que han aprendido las
últimas 23 horas
y en ese momento lo único que voy a
pasar por mi mente voy a tratar de
aprovechar la oportunidad pero lo que
ustedes acuérdense es que yo no sabía
cómo hablar en público en mi vida me ha
parado en frente entonces cuando nos
dicen que si alguien quería pasar dije
sabes que lo hará 5 segundos
voltea mi izquierda voltea mi derecho y
gestionarlo ante la mar los próximos
tres segundos sistemáticamente al
volante a la mano sin pensar que es lo
que estoy haciendo y haber ahí en el
camino de cómo me las arreglo
total volteo para atrás para la frente
in adelantó la mano ante la mano cuando
la mano
italia como me dicen algo importante ese
día es que yo traía la camisa de méxico
porque ese mismo día jugaba mexico en el
2014 en el mundial contra argentina lo
importante es el juego es que si no se
eliminó a si perdíamos ese partido no se
van a eliminar como siempre total
entonces escondió levante la mano me
dicen al post el de méxico porque tener
la camisa de méxico tal yo me paro en el
camino nada se empieza a caminar voltea
mi derecha y todos los 250 estudiantes
volteando a ver
en mi cabeza está haciendo qué está
haciendo porque mediante la mano estaba
bien agusto y sentado alguien más poder
pasado presentar yo estaba ahí para dar
con mis amigos pero tales voy caminando
y cuando su el escenario me pasa el
micrófono yo me paro
y por los próximos cinco mil no sale
ninguna palabra de mi boca
está plasmado no tiene nada que decir
de tantos nervios
en ese idioma pienso atacar de la risa y
todo el mundo se empieza a reír diciendo
lo que le pasa te lo ha cobrado sano
está diciendo nada total yo estaba el
encargado el directo y es que tiene que
contestar entonces todo mundo se empieza
a sacar de la risa ya mí es no es tu
nombre donde eres y algo interesante y
va ok total ya empiezo y todavía con voz
quebrantada verdad porque ya está un
poco más tranquilo porque todos están
riendo pero como quiera tenía yo
bastante miedo total empiezo bueno por
mí no me murió fernández soy de méxico y
todos se atacan de la realidad era pues
claramente tengo la camisa y cuando voy
a decir yo que cuál es algo interesante
que me ha pasado lo único que se me
puede ocurrir porque no tengan nada más
que contar era que antes de subirme al
avión de la ciudad de méxico a san
francisco empezó el partido de méxico
contra argentina
a dos horas un minuto cuando llegamos a
san francisco tres horas de vuelo lo
único que queríamos checar yo y mis
amigos es si méxico la había finalmente
ganar argentina el llegamos estamos en
las dos horas de inmigración y
obviamente en ese tiempo no existía
telcel y sin fronteras entonces nos
valió que eso aprendimos los datos y
llegamos a ver si méxico había ganado
entonces nos dimos cuenta que claramente
perdió mexico otra vez y que otra vez no
se han eliminado el mundial entonces
platicó su historia y todos atacan de la
risa que porque según yo bien macho con
la camisa de méxico y que otra vez nos
eliminaron total llama bajo el escenario
y cuando llegamos me siento mis amigos
como dije no tengo idea y en ese momento
yo me cuenta una cosa muy importante es
que uno tenía bastante miedo hablar en
público y ese mismo momento y uno me
cuenta que si nos ponemos en situaciones
incómodas algo que para mí no era nada
fácil es donde hay más oportunidades de
crecer ellos hay más oportunidades para
crear nuevas habilidades
y total
después de eso
después del campamento yo empecé a
relacionar como cada decisión que
tomamos nosotros si no me creen ahí
estoy yo con la camisa de méxico
presentando este total yo me di cuenta
en ese mismo día que cada decisión que
nosotros tomamos tienen algún tipo de
efecto a lo largo del camino y esa es la
verdadera razón por la cual estoy aquí
porque quiero compartir mi historia
en los términos más básicos para
aquellos que no saben qué es el efecto
dominó el efecto que dominó se considera
como un solo evento y en mi caso una
sola decisión que inicia y que
desencadena una cantidad de eventos
similares
por ejemplo eso fue cuatro horas después
ya me había parado a través del
escenario y ahí me traje en mi bailo
benestar tus nervios y taxis
porque el hijo de tu talento vienes y
total los que presentar unas cosas
entonces cada decisión que tomas afecta
de alguna forma u otra y nos acerca más
o nos aleja más de nosotros de nuestros
objetivos y de algo que yo estoy muy
seguro es que todos nosotros aquí
tenemos alguna meta o algún objetivo o
alguna idea frustrada de algo que
queramos realizar pero lo que también
estoy seguro es que todos nosotros aquí
tenemos una tendencia de dudar de dudar
antes de tomar una decisión ya sea que a
un negocio o ir al gimnasio o ya correr
en las mañanas o algo tan sencillo como
namas hablarle una chava en un antro lo
que sea que nos cause temor por
cualquier cosa tenemos una tendencia de
dudar y lo que va a tratar de hacer
ahorita es explicarles por qué y la
razón por la cual dudamos es porque
nosotros inmediatamente pensamos en esas
dos palabras en las consecuencias
inmediatas de la decisión que voy a
estar a punto de tomar qué va a pasar si
me paro al frente no puedo hacer el
ridículo de sant a reír de mí o que si
se volvía la mitad de la presentación
hoy la hablar un hacha en un antro
llegas y oye que si me manda la frenada
y le decía a sus amigas se van a reír de
mí
total cualquier cosa ir al gym la mañana
subir a correr en lo mismo en todas
partes siempre tenemos esta tendencia de
dudar y pensamos justamente lo que va a
pasar hoy y si empezamos a pensar en el
futuro de como cada decisión que tomamos
puede llegar a afectar a largo plazo en
donde vamos a estar parados
cambia totalmente la historia
si yo no hubiera tomado la decisión de
pasar al frente ese día en el campamento
cuando tenía 14 años y vencer ese miedo
mío que era hablar en público muy
probablemente no estuviera parado aquí
con ustedes el día de hoy y tampoco su
mujer ha abierto lo posible la
oportunidad más hermosa que he tenido en
mi vida yo no sé si recuerdan pero el
pasado 19 de septiembre un terremoto en
la ciudad de méxico que causó muchas
desgracias y eso a mí se me dio la gran
oportunidad así como 34 años de conocer
a que en su raid el founders de una
organización no esté no gubernamental en
eeuu se llama wario is life si no ha
tomado esa decisión de hablar en público
culpablemente enumeran y acercado con él
para decirlo esa es que me gustó mucho
tu idea la postrera méxico sólo hubiera
pasado y tampoco se hubiera abierto esta
posibilidad de faltar una semana entre
clases para poder ayudar a mi país
cuando más lo necesitaba
estudio y físicamente con estas personas
hicieron una parada en ese escenario ese
mismo día a vencer mis miedos muy
probablemente si es que hubiera ido a la
ciudad méxico ayudar a entregar los
filtros jamás hubiera entrenador phil
tumbar a la vuelta muy rápido
yo lo que tenía que hacer es explicarles
a todas las personas cómo funcionaban
estos filtros qué hacer para que durarán
más para alargar la vida del filtro
porque como ven el agua está saliendo
amarilla está espantoso
entonces si algo los que sí con algo los
quiero dejar de esta plática
es esto es que hablar sobre un filósofo
un filósofo griego es un hábil favorito
platón
una frase que él dice es que el comienzo
es la parte más difícil de cualquier
trabajo y estoy totalmente de acuerdo
con lo que él dice
es muy difícil empezar algo
lo que yo les puedo decir es pongan sus
situaciones incómodas y empiecen a hacer
así que ahora más los quiero dejar con
una última pregunta retórica
quien quiere pasar al frente es decir
cuál es su nombre ya lo que han
aprendido el de hoy muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]